so were you having that conversation
with your grandfather as you were like
pushing the pillow on his face yeah well
well it's interesting because a lot of
times you want to frame this as a
generational warfare issue but I think
it really isn't it's more of Washington
versus America's young not boomers and
the Silent Generation hi I'm Nick
Gillespie with Reason TV and today we're
talking with Jared Meyer he's the
co-author with Dianna furch got Roth of
disinherited how Washington is betraying
America's young Jared thanks for talking
to us hey thanks for having me there's a
huge generational swindle going on you
guys right in the first page this is the
first generation of young Americans that
our government systematically disfavors
and the first generation of Americans
whose prospects are lower than those of
their parents they have been
disinherited from their birthright what
are some of the actual material
indicators that young people are being
screwed in in a way that is historic
well I think if we look at the
unemployment rate right now for people
20 to 24 years old it's still 10% what
recovery is going on for them when
they've been left entirely behind and it
goes even further than that so not only
do they have unprecedented levels of
debt they're coming out of school
uneducated and unprepared to work and
there's plenty of government regulations
that keep them out from getting a job
after they even do finish okay well
let's let's walk through some of those
part one you guys talk about stealing
from the young to enrich the old so this
you're talking about stuff like Social
Security that takes money from
relatively young and relatively poor
people and gives it to relatively old
and relatively rich you always hear
people say well you know what you're
gonna pay for my health care now but
then your kids will pay for yours why
isn't this a virtuous cycle well that's
how the program sold is that you're
paying into it and you're eventually
going to get this money back and I
remember I had a conversation with my
grandparents which I'm sure a lot of
young people have about Social Security
and he told me I've paid into Social
Security my whole career I paid into
Medicare everything I'm getting now I
deserve it it was my money but instead
what happened is politicians have sold a
false bill they've said all these
programs that you're paying for now
you're gonna get the money you paid in
later but they've made promises where
they give benefit
now and push the cost off to the future
which means that current retirees are
getting far more back than what they
paid into the system so were you having
that conversation with your grandfather
as you were like pushing the pillow on
his face yeah well well it's interesting
because a lot of times you want to frame
this as a generational warfare issue but
I think it really isn't it's more of
Washington versus America's young not
boomers and the Silent Generation about
you know Medicare and Social Security I
think it's in your book you mentioned
it's basically about 40% or four out of
every ten dollars that spent are in
those programs and that percentage is
only going to go up you know what should
be done to Medicare and Social Security
well Social Security is an easier fix
all we need to do is realize that we
live in a different age now people live
longer they're more wealthy when they're
older so what we need to do is increase
the retirement age and also index
benefits to actual costs of living
rather than wages and so just simple
changes around the edges can bring
Social Security into balance and long
term Medicare is much scarier but it's a
difficult to predict because there could
be so much innovation and medicine that
costs may go down if we found let's say
a way to alleviate some forms of cancer
but right now the current traductor
trajectory it's on I would say Medicare
is a much scarier problem in an ideal
world at least we're in a libertarian
world wouldn't we get rid of these
programs and and not simply to say that
you know people should just fend for
themselves but Medicare was predicated
you know as much as Social Security on
the idea of old people who didn't have
insurance and would just die horrible
painful deaths that's not really the
case anymore many people are wealthy and
can afford their own insurance so should
we shift from in h bay if we're gonna
have a government provided social safety
net should we switch from an age base
one to a needs-based one would that be a
part I think that makes sense and also
just introducing more choice especially
in Medicare there's no reason you should
have to be kicked off your private
insurance once you turn 65 just to go on
Medicaid although legally you must
enroll in Medicare yeah so this doesn't
make any sense
and it's because they want to keep up
the facade that these are programs that
are social insurance we're all paying
for it but really starting to means-test
these programs is something we need to
do and
make it match the reality which is that
there are tax and transfer programs
where the young people are being taxed
and their Wells being transferred to
older Americans part two is keeping
young people uneducated and I'll speak
slowly because I realize you're younger
than I am
and you talk about the failure of K
through 12 education as well as the
explosion in college debt is is it true
that education is worse now than it was
say 30 or 40 years ago the stuff that I
see mostly is that results are about the
same but you know it's just that the
cost has gone up two or three percent
two or three times well I'd say American
students they have stayed about the same
but the rest of the world has shot ahead
of us so while the rest of the world is
adapting and improving their education
system the u.s. education system is
stagnating but this is one of the areas
where I'm the most optimistic we've seen
Nevada passing pretty much
individualized funding for students that
then they can save we've seen in a lot
of urban areas the growth at charter
schools and this is one area that I
think that debates pretty much won and
now we're gonna see more and more school
choice and I mean the Manhattan
Institute I know is is very free market
oriented and interested in the ways in
which markets are really discovery
processes I you know one of the things
that always struck me as odd is when in
an industry as vast as K through 12
education when you have everybody
basically doing the same thing you know
some kind of weird government and force
monopolies going on and that might end
with individualized learning right yeah
it could definitely chip away at it and
also chip away at the power of the
teachers unions and what I've seen cuz
we talk to a lot of teachers a lot of
students in the book and we discovered
that the teachers unions aren't even
standing up for teachers interests
instead what they're doing is looking
out for union bosses and current
retirees and they're making really a
system that goes against young teachers
as well as students well we'll leave it
there we've been talking with Jared
Meyer he's the co-author with the
Manhattan Institute's Diane
furchtgott-roth of disinherited how
Washington is betraying America's young
Jared thanks for talking to us hey
thanks for having me for reason TV I'm
Nick Gillespie